[Music]
are asap rocky and rihanna married well
kind of in the rapper's new music video
for his latest single dmb which stands
for that's my [ __ ] a love story between
himself and his girl ree is on full
display time to call it with the buzz
first i thought it wasn't none
probably think i wanna hit it run bad
girls wanna have fun the visual shows
the couple enjoying different spots in
new york together which eventually leads
to a proposal and wedding ceremony where
rihanna is seen rocking a red veil and
dress
[Music]
yeah that's rocky grinning with a grill
that reads marry me and rihanna
accepting his unique proposal with her
saying i do taking care of a girl
absolutely
[Music]
now it's unclear if art is imitating
life but rocky and rihanna who are
currently expecting their first child
together sparked engagement rumors back
in march when she rocked a huge sparkler
on that finger but a source told et at
the time she has had the ring in
question for a few years adding the pair
already consider themselves family but
when they are ready to tie the knot the
singer will make it clear if her and
asap have a wedding she will make the
aisle her runway in the meantime she's
totally been making everywhere she goes
her runway slaying all her pregnancy
looks
like
are you having fun with it well you have
to
see that i mean so it's a long nine to
ten months girl you know you you have to
enjoy it you were making it your fashion
show i'm trying to enjoy it as much as i
could and fashion is one of my favorite
things so
you know redefining what it means to
even be
pregnant and maternal you know it always
it it can get uncomfortable at times so
you know you can dress the part and
pretend but back to the music with rocky
pumping out hits while they wait for
their little one it may have the navy
posing a big question here's what she
told e.t yes you're still going to get
music from me maybe a lullaby i can see
you and asap dropping demos in the
studio
oh my goodness not a lullaby my fans
would kill me they waited this long for
a lullaby letting us sleep with this
music we are grown
[Music]